[Musik]
hier spielt die musik in paris
hinter aus ritzen hilfe in einer der
beiden inhaber von apropos concept store
wir sind seit gut 30 jahren im
modebusiness einzelhandel und haben
mittlerweile geschäfte in köln
düsseldorf hamburg und münchen
das erarbeiten der kollektion findet in
den showrooms stadt wir haben vier bis
sechs termine am tag unsere begriffs
planung wird anfang der saison gemacht
die pri kollektionen schreiben wir in
aller regel etwas breiter mit größerer
auswahl weil das zuerst mal die basis
ist wir geben etwa 70 prozent des
budgets immer für die pre kollektionen
aus und halten dann noch hier 30
für die schau kollektion sind zwischen
150 und 250 teile immer und da bemühen
wir uns natürlich für unsere kunden die
highlights rauszupicken wir hatten jetzt
eine lange zeit mit extrem sportive mode
also die ganze streetwear sportswear und
jetzt fängt es wieder ein bisschen
eleganter zu werden und konfektion
wieder wichtiger zu werden
paris im moment die spitze was also die
modischen aspekte angeht das macht er
eigentlich am meisten spaß die
kollektion hier zu erarbeiten
wir gehen als nächstes zur arbeit
[Musik]
so weit ist eine noch sehr junge marke
wir führen die herrenkollektionen
eigentlich sein beginn an ist eine
kollektion die sehr stark von unserer
neuen zielgruppe der millennials besucht
wird ist ein richtiger magnet in den
geschäften
wir haben mittlerweile sehr viele sehr
junge kunden wir haben aber auch
selbstverständlich unsere stammkunden
die wir schon seit 20 jahren oder mehr
bedienen
unsere teams werden entsprechend
geschult mit allen aspekten die wir
unterwegs im einkauf sehen warum wie
eine kollektion erarbeitet werden dass
sie auch den fragen der kunden die
mittlerweile im internetzeitalter sehr
gut informiert sind aufgewachsen sind
da stellen wir der mode mag sich
verändert haben was wir mittlerweile gut
finden und die herausforderung für uns
auch ist ist dass sich jeder designer
auf seine eigenen stärken konzentriert
es gibt also nicht mehr die trends an
sich als einzelne farben oder es teils
angeht kommenden donnerstag haben wir
ein event mit dem berliner salon haben
sechs kollektionen junger deutscher
designer im haus designer wie talbot
runhof oder logitech auch eine von den
jungen aufstrebenden deutschen designern
und wir unterstützen das sehr gerne
bieten da ein forum eine krise in dem
sinn haben wir gott sei dank nicht
verspürt man muss sehen dass wenn ein
designer ein bisschen nachlässt dass man
dann frische aspekte ins geschäft bringt
der sind da gerne experimentell halten
uns immer ein budget zum spielen dass
wir unseren kunden auch neue namen
bieten
und dann die entwicklung bei uns ist
immer spannend dann den mix zu sehen wir
zusammengestellt haben im laufe der
einkaufszeit der größte erfolg ist dann
wenn die teile an den kunden sind die
leidenschaft ist auch in 30 jahren noch
da diese auseinandersetzung die
herausforderung immer das richtige zu
treffen und immer wieder frische aspekte
zu sehen cage und sehr jung muss ich
sagen und den geist wach
[Musik]
mit